الى تركيا حيث قال الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ان عدد المباني المنهاره جراء الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا تجاوز 30 الفا وامتد
تاثيره على نحو 110 الف كيلو متر الجنوب
البلاد وحذر اردوغان في الوقت ذاته من ان
المنطقه ستمر بعاصفه من الزلازل ويجب ان
يتم الاستعداد لها واضاف ان اكثر من 90
دوله ارسلت فرقين قاده للمساعده خلال
كارثه الزلزال مشيرا الى ان جهود البحث
والانقاذ ادت دورا في تقليل الخسائر
البشريه
كما اكد اردوغان ان اكثر من نصف مليون
مواطن تركي قدموا مساعدات في عمليات
الانقاذ الى الان وفيما يتعلق بالانتخابات
المقبله اكد اردوغان ان انتخابات الرئاسه
والبرلمان ستجرى في الرابع عشر من مايو
المقبل مشيرا الى ان هناك من يحاول
استغلال الزلزال لاغراض سياسيه
وكانت الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه قالت ان
عدد قتل الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب شرق
تركيا في السادس من شباط فبراير الماضي
ارتفع عائله
وبذلك يرتفع العدد الاجمالي لقتل الزلزال
في تركيا وسوريا الى حوالي 51
الفاضافه البيان ان اكثر من 11 الف هز
ارتداديه حدثت عقب زلزالين ازاب تتواصل
عمليات رفع الانقاض في كهرمان مراجعه
التركيه والمناطق المتضرره الاخرى ولقد
تسبب زلزال وارتداداته حتى
الان اكثر من 100 الف شخص تركيا وقد تم
ايواء الملايين في خيام او انتقالهم الى
مدن اخرى
افاد مراسل الجزيره لدخول وفد من مكتب
تنسيق المساعدات التابع للامم المتحده من
معبر باب السلامه الى شماليه سوريا للوقوف
على احتياجات الاغاثه في الاثناء قال
الدفاع المدني السوري عدد الوفيات بسبب
وباء الكوليرا وصل الى 22 شخصا ووصل عدد
الاصابات الى نحو 600 في شمال غرب سوريا
اضافه الدفاع المدني ان اعداد الوفيات
والاصابات بالوباء مرشحه للزياده بسبب
دمار خطوط المياه والصرف الصحي الجراء
الزلازل الارتداديه المستمره في الشمال
السوري
عنتاب مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج ومن ادلب
ينضم الينا مراسلنا صهيب الخلف وابدا معك
من غازي عنتاب
عمر عن كيف يبدو الوضع هناك وما الذي يجري
الان من حيث اعاده ترميم المباني وايواء
المنكوبين كذلك
وسيله الهزات الارتداديه هي العنوان
الرئيسي ليوميات هذه المناطق المنكوبه
التي تضررت جراء هذين لدينا اللذان قبل
نحو شهر اخر الهزات المسجله وقعت في
ولايتها طاي وايضا في صباحا كان هناك ايضا
هزه اخرى في ولايه كهرمان مرش اللتان
سجلتا نحو من اربع من درجات على مقياس
ريختر اعنف الهزات الارتداديه على الاقل
خلال الاسبوع المنصرم سجلت في ولايه
ملاطيا اذ كان هناك بمقدار
5.6 ادت الى تهدم الكثير من الابنيه وقع
قتله نحو اربعه قتله وقعوا نتيجه هذه
الهزه وكان هناك المئات من الاشخاص اصيبوا
نتيجه انهيار بعض المباني الرئيس اردوغان
قبل قليل قدم نوعا من جرده حساب لهذه لهذا
الشهر المنصرم من
الزلازل الكبرى والهزات الرداديه حدث عن
تضرر اربعه ملايين مواطن تركي بشكل مباشر
نتيجه هذه الزلازل تحدث عن 30 الف بناء
تهدمت عند الزلزال وتحدث عن مئتين 200 200
الف مبنى
الحكومه مضطره الى الى هدمها نتيجه
الزلازل وانها تضررت تتصدعت بشكل كبير
وكذلك تحدث عن اعداد فرق الاغاثه اكثر من
275 الف من
منسوبي اداره الطوارئ التركيه وعن السفن
الحربيه التي باتت كملاجئ وماوى للمطورين
من الزلزال سته وثلاثين سفينه وايضا عشرات
المروحيات والطائرات التي كانت تنقل
المساعدات بشكل مباشر عمليات الايواء ما
تزال مستمره كما تشاهدون هنا هذه واحده من
ماتت تعرف
بمدن الخيام وسط مدينه عنتاب بالاضافه الى
المدن الاخرى التي تحولت الى مدن اصلاحيه
ونور داغي والمناطق الاخرى التي دمرت بشكل
كامل نتيجه الزلزال كلها تحولت الى منظر
مشابه من متجاهدون في الشاشه وذلك بالرغم
من عمليات الاصرار في هدم المباني وايضا
المحاوله ببدء انشاء مره اخرى على كل
الاحوال كذلك هناك حديث لوزير الدفاع
التركي يتحدث الان فيها عن جهود الانقاذ
ومره اخرى
السلطات تسابق الزمن لايواء كل هؤلاء
المتضررين